i think mike pineda who said not too
long ago hopefully this isn't his last
start as a twin a free agent after the
year he's been good when he's been out
there but he gives you a chance to win
every time he goes out there the wind up
and here it comes and that is strike
three called in 91 so vader strikes out
looking as pineda punches out his 84th
batter
and jeffers hangs on a foul tip cabrera
says it hit the ground home plate umpire
nestor ceja says no and
it's a base hit for grossman that's left
the board and a score in his first
inning for pineda casey my's last start
30th of the season really continued to
develop his pitches so here is byron
batting with the man on
tapper left side and buckston will get a
base head because the only play was to
aggressively charge it like that but
arise recognizing exactly what was going
to happen there here's polanco with two
men aboard and nobody out
high fly to center field retreating as
badou going back and gone
a three-run home run for jorge polanco
well he gets a night off of his seat
playing defense but you have to keep
that bad in the lineup with the way he's
swung all year 30-second home run of the
year gives the twins a nice
three-nothing lead and anytime big
mike's on the mound that feels like it
might be enough
had a couple of hits last night
including a double
gordon to our eyes and a double play
started nicely by gordon just gliding to
his left playing the hop flipping to his
second baseman for a big double play two
down there's that ground ball i was
asking for and not to donaldson not an
easy ground ball but gordon played this
perfectly great feed chest high able to
turn and get him easily jake at 185
playing time has not been there much
here feel what it's like to be pitching
in late september fastball strike three
perfect pitch 95 on the inside edge
three straight strikeouts for casey mize
nice play by candelario gets to his feet
and throws out jeffers bullet that's why
they call it the hot corner it has a
bullet right it hit something came up
candy made it look easy it's that
pre-pitch we're talking about
might hit right in the edge of the grass
in the dirt good reverse there i like
that you don't want to stand up and open
up you want to turn all the way around
after he'd been limited to three the one
two swinging a line drive under the
glove of a rise who completely
botched that one carol castro singled
his last time
up 02 off pineda grossman caught in
between they get cabrera at second
pineda didn't even look at grossman
scores on the play yeah he might have
had him you get him in the thigh
but when you get hit like that you're
the last thing you're he's looking at
percy he looks at his second base
it's a tough play actually a very good
base running play for robbie grossman he
does score
that stings a little bit and you know
with how much time he's missed that he
wants to pitch as deep into this ball
game as he can good to see him still out
there he faces miguel ceneaux nick
gordon and jake cave all three batters
he has struck out
got him at 95 at the bottom of the zone
almost surely the last battery faces in
2021 oh good in my book we've been
talking about it all night keeper
good room right center field alley
that'll hop all the way to the wall
extra bases for nico goodrum it's a
leadoff double here in the fifth pico
jumps right there that heater down the
middle good pitch
smacks it
easy double good room double cameron
struck out by do with an infield single
there's a strikeout and scope is out
number two
you see the spin on it right there just
tumbling starts in the zone i think the
reason he chases this because it was in
the middle of the plate you know he sees
it over the heart of the plate feel like
you can put it in
play out front
strike three work not done yet base hood
should tie this ball game up
there's a line driving to right field
kepper right there that ball was
scorched and right to max kepler they'll
strand two we're going to the bottom of
the fifth inning twins up three to one
jason foley is on to replace mice here
in the fifth it is his 11th appearance
of the season for detroit
the 2-2 to jeffers got him fastball
squarely in the strike zone
3-2 swung on him missed tigers pitching
dominating since the first but we head
to the sixth inning with the twins still
on top and here's manaya trying to get
the twins off the field with a two-run
lead it's the sign of the pitch
a little slow tapper is going to be
fielded by mania he'll under hand flip
to sono to retire nico goodroom and the
detroit tigers they get a couple hits
they strand two ryan now faces jonathan
scobe was grounded out flied out and
struck out
off of manaya
and arise quickly makes the play to get
it out the second comebacker targeting a
twins pitcher that was a really nice
play by louie arize who was
collapsing towards second base to get
the ground ball and then had to do a
180. yeah this really was a terrific
athletic play derek holland will work
the bottom of the seven for the tigers
his 39th appearance of the season he
works against jake cave ryan jeffers and
luisa rise the o2 ground ball soffit and
nico goodrum backhand flip to jamer
candelario fires it over to first got
him good play
six five three on the inning ending
double play neatly turned by goodram and
candelario we'll wait and see if the
twins challenge
they will not
last time up one and one
center field
buxton back
at the wall
and he caught it buxton robbed a
game-tying home run in the eighth inning
what a play that's a game saver right
there popped up with two on and nobody
out in the sixth
sharply hit up the middle of basement
kepler delivers buxton scores and the
twins finally get their fourth run
kepler the previous pitch out of play
just enough to give himself another
opportunity and barrel this ball headed
right through and drives in a big room
popped up short center hustling out his
good room coming in as badou
there's the catch donaldson is coming
home and he will score
he came a third of the way down
hesitated just a little bit and then
picked up his stride and scored on badou
i think he just saw that maybe he didn't
or he assumed he wasn't running and just
kind of kept going and i'm sure
donaldson did this on his own
instinctually you can run the bases a
little bit more aggressively and i think
nobody will appreciate that more than
gordon who'll be credited with the
sideline rbi totally last night had a
three-run lead and needed all three run
he gave up three singles and two runs
but ultimately when the game was being
decided he did strike out robbie
grossman to end the game the 2-1 ground
ball up the middle and into center field
daz cameron will score an rbi single for
jonathan scope to extend his hitting
streak to 10 in a row got the heater
right up the middle didn't roll it over
tigers finally get something going on
here in the top of the night
to third
donaldson sets
and the twin with back-to-back wins
against detroit
well nice ball game from the boyz there
always good to see a win
nice job by the pitching staff of hold
them down